I mean there really are no words and she
wanted to provide context there is no
context I literally read your word for
word and you're being a hypocrite coming
in here speaking out against hate speech
speaking out against violent rhetoric
and yet you are the very person who's
using hate speech in violent rhetoric to
put people's lives in danger
Craig yeah pretty obvious she really
showed they
you know um
I love moments like these it's great
it's like when you're a kid you used to
watch Happy Days and Fozzie would come
in and beat up the bully or I don't know
Steve Austin would be Bigfoot it's like
a great TV moment where the person who
deserves it has it coming they're like
terrible people at these hearings she's
not even the worst I mean there were
people there that are saying
parents should not be told if their kids
are seeking transition or or I mean it
this is a cult it's a cult and and it's
and also I think you know it I think the
con it's just congresswoman right yeah I
think so right yeah anyway she makes a
great Point by attempting attempting to
censor anybody by labeling language of
incitement it could be used on everybody
and on anybody because it's so open to
interpretation the way misinformation
disinformation and especially hate
speech is we've seen this Broad and
Broad and broadened you think the
activists this activist might learn from
this now she blocked mace she blocked
her on Twitter that was the lesson she
didn't want to she didn't want to hear
from her again she also blocked me she
blocked she I think she blocked just
everybody from Fox it just shows you
that she she prefers to live in her own
bubble she prefers to live her own
cognitive bias so when she commits the
crime of of of saying I hope Katie
Pavlich gets attacked she doesn't see
that the same way that somebody will
will say you should get attacked because
she's in a bubble she can't see she only
sees the crime when the person she hates
is doing it yeah Jessica we hear that
the threats to democracy are very
serious that all of the what goes on on
Twitter especially needs to be taken
seriously that Elon Musk is allowing for
this plethora of hate speech to thrive
on the platform And yet when people like
this do it they think it's okay and
there's no recourse for them well we'll
see if there is some recourse this
moment has gone pretty viral and I think
this also speaks to the importance of
having Representatives on both sides
like a Nancy Mays who Republicans and
Democrats respect right this is not a
flame-throwing person this is not
someone who uses her language fast and
loose right this is someone who takes
her job very seriously and that's why
that was so effective and yes she was on
our Network and she also went on to a
more liberal Network to talk about it
she's someone who takes interviews by
anchors of the other party and that's
important that's how you make your
message heard showing up in places where
people wouldn't expect you to be there
so that was something I took away from
it and I think it's interesting because
it does mirror I think it was Twitter
files installment three or four whatever
it was the debate about whether Donald
Trump's tweet was inciting violence
right and hinged on who are the American
Patriots that he's talking to was he
talking to the the guys who stormed the
capital or is he just talking to
American Patriots writ large right
people who voted for him but are sitting
at home in Kentucky minding their own
business and we're going to have to
spend a lot more time thinking about
what really incites violence is it all
just what's flat out on the page is it
how someone interprets it and what they
go and do based on it what kind of
intent can we put does that woman who
was testifying want them to show up at
all of their houses no people did show
up I understand including someone who
wanted to kill Supreme Court Justice
Brett Kavanaugh and the media also agree
with that Jesse do you not tweet because
you're worried about getting called in
front of Congress to testify about
something someday uh uh Johnny tweets I
don't know what he says but I haven't
gotten in trouble so far so he's doing a
great job this is the liberal logic
if I call a transsexual he they will say
oh you're causing violence but if a
transsexual says a mob needs to turn
loose into Justice's house and get in
their face that's free speech and that
is BS and the problem is is that that
argument doesn't get a fair Shake in the
media
so if you say anything the media will
say you're causing violence and not only
are you causing violence you're causing
violence to the most vulnerable to those
that are most depressed and no one wants
to cause violence to anybody and you
can't even remember what you said at
that point so it's just another way to
censor you and I will not stand for it
way to way to stand up for free speech I
need to stand up
you're in a mood today
a federal judge a liberal federal judge
whose son was gunned down and her and
her husband was shot as well and yeah so
there is real violence
because you guys had to fund the police
that's the same thing all right